but now i i uh
i want to show something from one of
your shows i think it happened last
season and then you tell me how i'm
supposed to feel about this all right
all right just go ahead this is from the
louis ck show
hey letterman i did it
[Music]
honestly what
why i always
[Laughter]
i didn't mean you no
this guy jimmy let her jimmy
is the best advice you can give for like
a student and like attitude
when you're doing that because you kind
of say a big few to a lot of people and
i like that
say you mean
i like attitude when you're um
when you're yeah when you're in the
production which you've done at all
and what's the best attitude to really
get the best attitude in production
is really uh
really wanting to help a lot
uh really wanting to help whoever's
show it is
uh be really great i mean just i mean i
think that's anybody who's doing any job
really
should want that job to be done really
well i mean this is a simple answer but
it's really true
there's one person really usually that
has an idea of how to do something and
everybody else should really want i mean
it's such a
rare and great gift to get a job in show
business it's very very it's not you're
not going to get one
i mean statistically you're you're not
so you're saying this is how you
actually talk i'm talking like my mama
taught me to talk and if you clown on my
mom's and you's about to get bounced
okay if that's how you really talked in
we ain't got a problem mm-hmm well okay
then
i remember you weren't of this world to
me you were like
i just had never seen anybody that looks
like you
or
she talks like the average we're like a
like a alien who studied
human behavior
and got close but didn't quite get there
i don't believe in it i don't believe in
raising your kids rich
is the worst thing you can do
for them or really more for the people
that they're going to impact later in
life yeah because there's no way
somebody who's raised rich
is not going to be a piece of human
being just no way i mean and i know
i know
i mean if you're raised rich if you get
rich through work that's okay but if you
were a kid that got was given a porsche
when he was 17 right what are the
chances oh he's so sage and cool that
guy who got a free sports car when he
was a child
i don't believe like and it's why the
world is a little messed up because
until like a minute ago historically
right the rule was that if the king died
his kid got to run the country that's
the craziest system
the king is dead who of the whole nation
can we count on to move us forward
well there's copernicus he's really
smart nah
let's see the king's son is 17. he's
been living in a castle and raping
chambermaids for three years
let's let's let him run everything
yeah he drinks chocolate for dinner
love it or do you hate it but he's
bothering me so much lately
when i was a kid i was bullied but i was
bigger i was bigger and i was bullied
you're still bullied even though you're
basically bullied by littler kids than
me oh no this way this is a flashback
and i was bigger i could beat this
i wish i could bring home more money hey
i was on a plane i was going flying out
to los angeles recently for a lot of
important stuff and i was in the in
sitting on an aisle seat with two you
know with three seats and it was like a
very crowded stressful flight
and we're about to take off and this
woman gets on
with her baby like this
and her husband and two other just sad
looking kids and she's just walking
through the plane hating people with her
baby
she's so upset and i saw her come and i
realized that she's sitting
here no
and i'm like uh so she comes up and she
says okay here's how this is going to
work
this is all true she goes you're sitting
in the middle i'm sitting in the aisle
because i have a baby
oh and i
thought okay
and i told her here's what i'm going to
do i'm going to get off the plane
just get up so i get off the plane
i don't get why there's an fcc that can
make those rules i don't understand it
it doesn't jive with what i understand
about america and the first amendment it
just doesn't make any sense to me
what
yeah
but
let me finish
but part of it was i want to cut out the
middleman that's an exciting idea i make
a show i i literally out put it on my
macbook and you watched it on your ipad
that was exciting to me yeah sure um but
here's the thing when you cut out the
middleman you deal with the customers
directly are you really dealing with the
customers i don't i mean i read some of
the emails i get like one guy wrote to
me after i was on the air for three
weeks and he said i'm still on the fence
about trying your show
i don't know if i want to spend the five
dollars
so can you write me an email try to
convince me to watch your show
i'm like you know take your five dollars
and shove it up your ass
like i just got mad
because
i'll take an 11 30 p.m nap
and go to bed at midnight oh come on yes
because i don't take a nap because i
need one i i just love it's my favorite
thing you like it better than sleep
sleep is like the ultimate nap
you really that's stupid you just said
that
there's a dumb thing to say what are you
talking about such a dumb thing to say
you know kids are mean and it's because
they're trying it out
they they look at a kid and they go
you're fat and then they see the kid's
face scrunch up and they go oh that
doesn't feel good to make a person do
that but they but they got to start with
doing the mean thing but when they write
your fat then they just go hmm that was
fun i like them
so
i think a lot of people don't do their
job because they don't like their job
i don't get that you know like if you go
to like a coffee place in the and the
kid looks you like uh
i'm like i didn't come to your house to
ask you for coffee it's a coffee place
if you work here your clothes matched
the building i had a right to expect
and you're closer
you know you're closer to the coffee
machine i don't know why and i need
coffee i don't know why someone wouldn't
want their job to go really well right
and i i think usually it's because
they're 20. because they're 20 year old
douchebags that don't want to do i am
prejudiced against 20 year olds really
yeah because 19 you're still your
parents fault right 20
you're technically an adult but you
still haven't done anything like 20 year
olds at their jobs are always like this
job sucks yes that's why we gave it to
you
because you're 20.
you're 20 year old gold you haven't done
anything you've never you've just been
sucking up resources you've just been
taking food and love and education and
ipods and just taking it and judging it
you're like
that sucks you're like a big orange on a
tree that's rotting and the tree's like
get off what you know
she's where you want to go like you're
hanging on
[Applause]
[Music]
driving i was i was living here at the
time and i was driving really fast i was
speeding because i was in a hurry so i
was making other people almost die
because i my bad judgment
so i'm driving and then i realized
there's a car next to me who's driving
fast it's a kid like 19 years old a
green honda that he made at his house
[Applause]
he's got spiky hair
and he keeps so i'm like good i don't
care you know let's both get to my show
on time i'm fine
he thinks we're racing i'm not racing
but so we get to the next red light and
he's looking at me and he's going
like this and i go what happened to your
hand like i don't understand what this i
don't know what that means
if other people don't know the thing it
doesn't scare them
he's like
and i'm like i don't know it
so
he goes i go i said to him listen i'm
not trying to go fast relative to you i
just have my own independent reason
for my speed
and he got angry at all the words and
everything and
he pulled out a gun
and he pointed it at me so i go through
the red light
and
he does too
and i was like oh like i like i'm
thinking oh he's trying to kill me but
he's not going to go through a red light
you know
i'm sure he's thinking ahead to
how that's going to hurt his insurance
premiums in the long run so now i'm in a
car chase
in l.a i'm being chased and it doesn't
feel like a car chase
it's a beautiful day i'm listening to
simon and garfunkel on my radio
being chased you i am just a poor boy
though my story
so i call 911
on my cell phone and i go uh there's a
guy
chasing me with a gun and he's trying to
kill me that's what i said
and the lady goes why is he doing that
i swear to god
why is he doing that
i'm like is there a reason he could have
that you would not send anyone to help
me
like if i tell her the story
[Applause]
like i'm gonna tell her the story and
she's gonna go it sounds like you made a
mess for yourself we're not gonna get
involved so i did the same thing any
time i call a company and i don't like
what you hang up you call again right
right get another person get another
person so i get another guy he goes 911
emergency and i tell him and helicopters
show up right away helicopter i guess i
just sound white enough to call in an
airstrike
i'm nervous but
sometimes people ask me for pictures uh
and i don't like doing it what no why
not well i know you're just supposed to
you're supposed to go well you know the
fans but i just go no i don't want to do
it right
so
it just makes me uncomfortable yeah but
one time like so i always try to be nice
how i say no i go oh you know but thank
you you know okay so i was coming out of
a restaurant once and these two women
are standing there and i hear them and
say
picture picture so i go oh no i'm sorry
i i just don't like doing that right i
hope that's okay and they're like
they're like okay
and i said what's your name though
and she's like janet
and i go hi jin and i'm louie hi hey
guys i'm sorry but thank you and then i
walk away and i see the two women give
their camera to some guy to take their
picture
with each other
i just want to say i'm not trying to say
that if you're white you can't complain
right i'm just saying that if you're
black you get to complain more right
right because
you can't
there you go don't tell the band that
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
because you can't you get this right
you can't take people's like historical
context away from them and everybody
wants us to like white people are always
like come on it wasn't us like they want
black people to forget everything
like every year
white people add a hundred years to how
long ago slavery was
i've heard educated white people say
slavery was 400 years ago no it very
wasn't
it was 140 years ago that's two 70 year
old ladies living and dying back-to-back
that's how recently
you could buy a guy that's it and it's
not like slavery ended and then
everything has been amazing like it just
oh glad that's over oh yeah it just
ended like a clean where you don't have
to wipe just boom and then it's just
been
parades
and presents ever since
you got it
you got to remember that if you meet a
black person they have gray hair they
remember a time they weren't allowed to
use a certain toilet so give them a
little you know time to be cranky and by
the way white people have our own thing
that we stuff that we went sure sure
that that hurt us that we have to cope
with like when they took our slaves away
that was really hard for us
and we're still
so it's pretty even i mean you didn't
have did you you were were you a bad kid
i wasn't a bad kid but i got in trouble
because i just was alone and i just you
know like i got into stealing tampons
for profit
no i didn't make a dime
i didn't make a dime how did this work
i was eight years old and i just went
into a cvs one day because i just roamed
store aisles
and uh and i was at looking at the
tampons and i was sort of staring at
them with this
i knew there was something dirty about
them
and i picked one up i got the gall to
pick one up and i'm looking at this box
of tampons and someone came around the
corner so i put in my jacket
and now i have stolen them
because if i take them out that someone
saw that i had them in my chat in my
head i'm like that's it they're in there
i can't so
i just i left and i had sweat on my face
and i just went home and i threw them
under my bed and i'm eating dinner like
everybody knows i have tampons in my bed
and so it was a terrible stressful
experience which i then repeated every
day
for like two months
i'd go back and i just do the whole
cycle i just kept doing
it and no i never got caught i mean they
probably saw me but the guy's like i'm
not confronting the kid
i'll pay for him out of my check before
i live that moment
i'm not asking that little pervert what
he's doing
there's something wrong with that boy
what's really wrong with him and how did
it end well they kept going under my bed
and i just tried not to think about them
and then one day i looked and they were
just gone they just were gone and my
mom never said anything
she just she must have been cleaning up
and she was like what the [ __ ]
what is this this is crazy
wow i don't know maybe she used them for
like 10 years
would she throw them away